♪♪
-Did a show last weekend
in my hometown --
Manchester, New Hampshire.
It's where I went
to high school.
And before the show,
the outgoing mayor, Joyce Craig,
gave me this --
a key to the city.
Very cool.
Think a lot of people would
hang this on the wall
so they could see it
every day...
feel proud about themselves.
But I'm not that kind of guy.
I'm gonna put it on the floor.
[ Laughter ]
Because I'm low-key.
See me next week.
[ Laughter ]
No?
Alright.
It's gonna be hard to follow,
though.
I said Harry Potter
wouldn't wear New Balance.
And it turns out
there's a brand-new shoe
made specifically for wizards.
HOKAS POKAS.
See me next week.
[ Laughter ]
No?
Um...
"Harry Potter" took place
in 1991.
Came out in 1997.
I remember when it came out,
a lot of my friends
read "Harry Potter."
Former friends.
I could not stay friends
with people in their 20s
who was reading --
who were reading books
about, you know, boy wizards.
I was busy reading another book
that came out
in the late '90s.
"Infinite Jest."
And I'm almost done with it.
[ Laughter ]
All tortoises are turtles.
Good for them.
[ Laughter ]
I said, "Begs the question."
Many of you said
that was incorrect.
Based on the sentence structure,
I should have said,
"Raises the question."
So I looked it up.
And here's what I found.
"The fallacy
of begging the question
occurs when
an argument's premise
assumes the truth
of the conclusion
instead of supporting it.
In other words, you assume
without proof the stand position
or a significant part of
the stand that is in question.
Begging the question is also
called arguing in a circle."
So, thanks to that definition
being super-clear...
[ Laughter ]
...I wrote up an example.
A jackal said "Corrections"
was boring, self-indulgent,
and long,
begging the question,
[bleep] do I care?
[ Laughter ]
We, in "A Closer Look,"
had Trump --
transcripts of Trump going
back and forth with the judge.
Trump saying, "Am not."
Judge saying --
Sorry. Trump said, "Am too."
Judge said, "Am not."
"Am too." "Am not."
People pointed out --
Trump should have said, "Am to,"
the judge should have said,
"Are not."
That is correct.
We made a mistake.
I went to Sal and I said,
"I don't think you're
paying enough attention
to the granular details
of the 'Closer Look' scripts."
And he said, "Am too."
[ Laughter ]
We did a bit where Sidney Powell
said the election was stolen
by the ghosts of Chester Cheetah
and Mr. Peanut.
This upset a lot of you.
[ Laughter ]
Because you all pointed out,
"You should have said,
'Chester Cheetah
and the ghost of Mr. Peanut.'"
Because Mr. Peanut did die.
In a --
He died in January of 2020.
This is -- This feels
like a bit. This is not a bit.
He died in an ad campaign.
It was part of
a Super Bowl ad campaign.
Planters thought they could
get away with killing Mr. Peanut
because it's never sad
when someone who wears a monocle
dies.
[ Laughter ]
We said Rudy Giuliani did
a paint-by-numbers of a unicorn,
and then the graphic
was very clearly
a connect-the-dots of a unicorn.
So, of course,
I marched down to Graphics
and I said, um...
"I'm very angry."
And they were like --
[Groaning]
"We hope you're not mad at us."
And I'm like,
"I am mad at you."
They're like,
"Ohh. What did we do?"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Well, you know,
what bothers me is you --
I asked for paint-by-numbers,
and you did connect-the-dots.
And I think you did that
on purpose
because I think your kink
is me coming down here
and being upset,"
and they were like,
"Ohh! Look who's
connecting the dots now!"
[ Laughter ]
UH, I mimed --
Well, I didn't mime.
We had -- We had fake cigarettes
and I was smoking.
And I was told
by a bunch of people
that's not how
you smoke a cigarette.
And it's true. I don't know
how to smoke. Never smoked.
And so I can't correctly,
you know, fake-smoke and, uh...
I'll regret for the rest of
my life that I didn't smoke.
So I don't know how to do it.
The rest of my life,
which based on actuarial tables
will be a great deal longer
than those of you who do.
[ Laughter ]
[ Sighs ]
Mr. Pibb...
was rebranded to Pibb Xtra
in 2001.
I guess what happened
was Mr. Pibb got a divorce.
Then, like a lot
of divorced guys,
he wanted to let everybody know
he was, like, fun now.
So he changed it up.
Very funny
that they didn't realize
the problem with the name
Mr. Pibb was "Pibb."
Like, to change the name
and keep the "Pibb,"
which is just a --
It's just unsatisfying
to say "Pibb."
But, yeah.
Don't worry about Mrs. Pibb.
She, after the divorce,
married Mr. Peanut.
Then he died,
and she's rolling in it.
Cha-ching!
Cha-ching! She's rolling.
You know what she's rolling in?
Legume money.
[ Laughter ]
"They call me Mr. Pibb!"
I knew I'd get it in.
[ Laughter ]
Oh. This one.
Again, the smoking thing.
I was like,
"Hey, we're gonna do it.
And this brings us to new bit,
"Seth Mutters for a Second."
"Stares Off into the Distance
and Mutters for a Second."
A bunch of you said
that was 47 seconds.
That was more than a second.
And my kids do that
all the time, too.
Like, I'll say,
"Can you give me a second?"
And they'll be like,
"That was a second!"
And let me just say
to all of you,
my kids included --
funny every time you do it.
[ Laughter ]
Uh, an expert reached out.
And you know
what kind of experts
leave comments in the
"Corrections" YouTube page?
The kind whose credentials
you can't check.
[ Laughter ]
Expert reached out and said,
"Most animal venoms
would not be poisonous
to ingest."
So bottoms up.
[ Laughter ]
Envenomation.
I learned this word.
Envenomation is exposure
to a toxin or poison
resulting from a bite or sting
from an animal.
Devenomation is when you get
bit by a poisonous animal
and fall out a window.
[ Telephone ringing ]
Hello? Mm-hmm.
Okay.
I was just told
that was an old callback.
[ Laughter ]
What are we doing?!
What is this?!
Why do I spend all day,
like, e-mailing people,
asking them for an old phone?!
[ Laughter ]
Like, what do I think
is gonna happen?!
[ Laughter ]
[ Sighs ]
Last week in "Corrections."
I called it Shoemaker's wedding,
and a lot of you said
it wasn't Shoemaker's wedding.
It was Shoemaker's daughter's
wedding.
But I can tell you,
around the office,
when you call it Shoemaker's
daughter's wedding,
he will say,
"Oh, she paid for it?!"
[ Laughter ]
A lot of you were mad
that we showed
me stumbling on the end
of "A Closer Look"
and still didn't tell you
what I was saying
when it sounded like
I was speaking Welsh.
What I was saying is,
"Get angry at prosecutors."
Let's hear and see
how close I was.
Geddankry at prosecutors.
[ Laughter ]
It's like I recorded it
backwards.
It's like David Lynch.
"Geddankry ahproskoter."
[ Laughter ]
I talked about Jim Breyer
last week,
and someone wrote,
"Who the hell is Jim Breyer?"
[ Laughter ]
I'm not --
I'm not gonna tell you,
but I will tell you
those would be the...
last words you ever said...
[ Laughter ]
...if he was within earshot.
"Hey, uh, Jim Breyer says
you can't stay in there."
"Who the hell Is Jim Breyer?!
Ohh!"
[ Laughter ]
People who go to Ren Faires
are called Rennies.
So keep that in mind
if you're ever yelling at one
out an open car window.
[ Laughter ]
Carnival workers are called
carnival workers.
[ Laughter ]
Hey. We had a thing.
We were talking about how
the new Speaker of the House
and his son were on an app,
told each other when
they were watching pornography.
It's like a pornography
monitoring app.
And then we said, "Thank God
Joe Biden and Hunter
don't have that
on each other's phone."
And then, um...
I had a -- Joe -- His phone was
bing, bing, bing, bing bing.
And he took it, and he --
One of the things
I had him say was,
"Ah, come on, Hunter.
Get ahold of yourself."
More than one of you said if
Hunter was watching pornography,
he would likely already
have ahold of himself.
[ Laughter ]
There just wasn't a lot
this week.
I know we have to fill it
for the advertisers.
[ Laughter ]
At a certain length.
Just won't run their ads.
We talked about
"Silence of the Lambs."
Was it a well?
Was it a cistern?
There's a French word for it
I always forget.
Oh. Oubliette.
[ Woman laughs ]
All I wanted was one. Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
The most heartbreaking thing
that happened
is you covered your mouth.
If she does that again,
slap those [bleep] hands away!
[ Laughter ]
So, someone said, "Is it a well
or was it a cistern?"
So a very actual helpful
Jackal...
went to the book,
the Thomas Harris book
"Silence of the Lambs,"
because there
there is clarity.
These are the words
describing it.
"In the basement room
directly beneath the kitchen
was a well, long dry.
Its stone rim reinforced
with modern well rings."
He wanted us to know
it was a well so much,
he put in
that "well rings" part.
Really hammered it home.
"The floor, a well floor."
[ Laughter ]
"Of that one could be certain.
The doorbell rang.
Jame Gumb opened
to reveal Agent Starling.
'How are you doing?' she asked.
'Good,' he said, knowing
it was incorrect grammatically
but desperate not to
get her thinking about wells."
[ Laughter ]
You know what
this "Corrections" is?
Not for everybody.
[ Laughter ]
Um, on Halloween -- I forgot
to show this last week.
On Halloween, an audience member
came in costume,
and her costume
was Cue Card Wally.
And I will just say,
while we'll allow it once,
people dressing like Wally
is not helpful...
...in regards to what we're
affectionately referring to
as our Wally Problem.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, you know, when we have
a music guest,
I'll hold up the album art.
Because someone
referred to the fact
that I was holding
the vinyl wrong.
It is not a vinyl.
I am not holding an album.
It is simply the album art
cut to be the size of an album.
And I -- I did not know that
when I started the show.
I had -- Obviously like
the rest of you,
I'd watch shows and I had
assumed it was an album.
And I was so excited
when I got this show
that I would get an album
every time we had
a musical guest.
And just imagine now.
Imagine, after all the shows
we've done,
if I had an album from
every musical guest we'd had.
Just imagine --
If that was true,
imagine how many times my wife,
Alexi, would have said to me,
"So do you have, like, a plan?"
[ Laughter ]
"For all these records?"
This is what I forgot last week.
Got another one of these
in the mail.
♪ Nothing in the world
could be worse than me ♪
♪ I'm the worst thing
that you'll ever see ♪
♪ Excuse me real quick,
what did you say? ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ I'm worse than you
each and every day ♪
♪ We're gonna [bleep]
in your nightmares ♪
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
Can we -- Can we say
another thing?
It -- They're -- By the way...
those are tails.
[ Laughter ]
...like this.
[ Mouthing words ]
[ Sighs ]
[ Laughter ]
See me next week.